[Music]
one of the concepts that comes up over
and over again with prolific creative
minds that I've interviewed for the Tim
Ferriss show or for the book tools of
titans is creating empty space and one
of the guests Josh Waitzkin who never
does any media can I curse on this yeah
he always texts me with profanity-laden
sms's because I'm the only one who can
pull him out of his cave to do media but
he is best known perhaps as the chess
prodigy and I'll explain why I put that
in air quotes
besides how funny it looks on camera
that form the basis or who formed the
basis for searching for bobby fisher'
both the book and the movie he was very
well known chess player and continues to
be an incredible chess player but he has
applied his learning framework to more
than chess so he was a world champion in
Tai Chi push hands it's the first black
belt in Brazilian jiu-jitsu under the
Phenom probably the best of all time
marcelo garcia who trains in new york
city and he's a nine-time world champion
something like that and he's now
tackling paddle surfing and he could
apply to just about anything he works
with some of the top financial minds in
the world
hedge fund managers and beyond the best
of the best top 1% so why what are the
principles that he shares one of them is
creating empty space cultivating empty
space as a way of life and these are all
tied together so much and another one
learning the macro from the micro and
then beginning with the end in mind and
these all work together so I'll explain
in fact the last two first
Josh learned to play chess or I should
say more accurately was coached by his
first real coach in the opposite
direction when compared to most training
in most chess books he was taught in
Reverse what does that mean he began
with the endgame and with very few
pieces so they cleared all the pieces
off the board instead of starting with
openings meaning what do you do first
the first five to 10 moves start with
the endgame
with King and pawn versus King what does
this do well this forces you to focus on
principles like opposition creating
space Zeb's wong which is a principle of
forcing your opponent to do anything
that will destroy their position or
anything they can possibly do well worse
in their position and these types of
principles that you learn when there's
an empty board with a few pieces
accomplished a few things number one you
are learning the macro the principles
that you can apply throughout the game
of chess in almost any scenario through
the micro this this endgame situation
and these principles are adaptable you
become a machine that can bob and weave
with the circumstances very effectively
compared to that as Josh would put put
it if you're memorizing the openings
okay and this might be like memorizing
recipes if you learn to cook you're
effectively stealing the answers from
the teacher's guide book to a test and
you'll be able to beat your friends for
a while and maybe even be considered a
pretty decent chess player but on a deep
level you don't understand the game and
you will not you'll hit a ceiling and
you will never progress past that and
you'll get beaten by really good players
so that can be applied to for instance
Brazilian Jujitsu Josh told taught me
basically all of the most important
principles of jiu-jitsu through one move
at the end game which is a a choke
called
the guillotine which Marcelo is famous
for his version is called the Marcelo
teen but it's effectively like this
you're choking someone's head here and
he has a weird way of doing it where he
puts his forearm on top of your shoulder
it's pretty wicked
if you want to be put on conscious you
can go to that gym and experience it
yourself but that can also be applied to
many many other things for instance if
you're trying to build a startup all
right this is this is a common trendy
thing to do these days and I think
everybody should start a business at
some point but in the start-up game and
say Silicon Valley where I live if
you're going to go into the
venture-backed world well you and your
founder better think a lot about the end
game and
you should definitely have an agreement
at least a working agreement a tentative
agreement on what type of exit say
acquisition offer is acceptable to you
if those those end goal components
aren't in place then it's just a
slow-motion train wreck waiting to
happen and how might you do that well if
you're trying to learn the macro from
micro you could think about what the
acquisition agreement might look like so
you could talk to lawyers get a sample
template agreement and look at the
provisions look at the clauses and then
reverse engineer it so that when you're
forming the company when you're hiring
employees your decisions at that point
make it possible to have that contract
at the end this is another example Micro
maybe it's a 10 20 page document macro
building a company that gets acquired by
a much much larger company so that is
learning the macro from the micro
another example just because I brought
up cooking would be same choosing a
recipe that involves two or three
primary techniques and perhaps three to
five primary ingredients that apply in
many many many different dishes so
you're learning principles of say flavor
combination principles of using
convection versus shallow frying or
sauteing versus steaming okay that apply
across the board and in doing so let's
say you do it without a recipe without a
timer or I should say a meat thermometer
or something like that you're going to
learn also to test the food to know
whether it is done or not that then
applies to everything but you can do it
just learning how to make harissa crab
cakes with steamed broccoli and I have
no idea say candied yams something like
that all right so that's that now then
we also Brawl talking about the endgame
so we've covered that creating or
cultivating empty space is way of life
this is very important to Josh Waitzkin
who I mentioned it's very important to
people like Paul Graham who's the
co-founder of Y Combinator which is like
the Navy SEALs hard
of startup accelerators keeping it
simple let's let's just call it that for
now creating if you are a creator if you
are a maker and not a manager this is
important
creating three to five which by the way
is a decision so a lot of really good
entrepreneurs start as a technician or
tactician they're very very good at one
thing then they end up in a managerial
role that they hate doesn't mean you
have to stay there and you see a lot of
folks like Evan Williams and others who
then at some point realize this and
return to a more product focused role
even if they are also the CEO making
some high-level 30,000 foot decisions
okay but if you are a maker if you've
decided to be a maker if you just happen
to be maker or creator let's call it
three to five hour uninterrupted blocks
of time are extremely critical if you
want to connect the dots if you want to
have the space to allow yourself to have
original ideas or at least original
combinations of ideas you really need to
block out that time and protect it at
least once a week so in tools of titans
there are many people who do this we're
meet SETI for instance was a very very
successful multi multi-million dollar
business that he built out of a blog he
started long ago in college which was
very very niche and its focus he blocks
out I believe it's every Wednesday for
three to five hours of time you'll block
it out for learning Noah Kagan another
entrepreneur does the same thing so on
Wednesdays for me I have from 9:00 a.m.
to 1:00 p.m. this is pre lunch I have
creation that means writing recording or
some similar aspect of in my mind
creating with with my skill set in my
assets and it is extremely important
that I do that before I ambhiraj my
inputs in other words and this is true
of Josh as well first thing in the
morning he's doing journaling Reed
Hoffman billionaire co-founder or
founder of LinkedIn same story he will
plant a seed in his mind the night
before a problem he wants to solve
project he wants to think about
improving perhaps and then waking up the
tabula rasa complete blank slate
immediately working on that problem with
journaling before any text messages
before any email which is why for
instance I don't have email setup on my
phone I do not have mail setup on my
iPhone I not get notifications I also
put my phone on airplane mode for a lot
of reasons thank you for the 4-hour body
explain some of the physical ones but on
to airplane mode when I go to bed and it
stays in airplane mode until I'm done
with my creation period and then it
comes on because as soon as you go into
bullet-dodging or like wonder one bullet
blocking mode with everyone else's
agenda for your time which is very often
the inbox or text messages your DOA
you're done your creativity is is all
for not in general so for for me for
many people who are say programming for
musicians for creative types slack in
the system you have to create slack you
have to create space you have to create
large uninterrupted blocks of time and
the only way to do that is to put it on
your calendar if it's not on your
calendar it's not real you need to put
it in your calendar and defend it just
like you would anything else
[Music]